[Música]
Jair bolsonaro testificó en una
audiencia por la investigación que lo
acusa de quedarse con joyas de Arabia
Saudita cuando era presidente de Brasil
el Antiguo mandatario acudió al cuartel
general de la Policía Federal en
Brasilia Tenemos reporte de nuestro
corresponsal
por segunda noche consecutiva la policía
de Israel irrumpió en la mezquita de
galaxia en Jerusalén mientras los
musulmanes oraban por el ramadán desde
Estados Unidos y Turquía hasta el jamás
han rechazado estos operativos
y Beijing prometió una firme respuesta
contra Estados Unidos y los acusó de
romper su compromiso de respetar la idea
de una sola china todo porque este
miércoles la presidenta de Taiwán
se reunió con el republicano Kevin
mccarthy presidente de la cámara de
representantes estadounidenses
Bienvenidos a las noticias
internacionales de France 24 yo soy
María Clara calle y es un placer
acompañarlos comenzamos en Brasil Jair
bolsonaro fue este miércoles al cual al
cuartel general de la Policía Federal de
Brasilia para testificar en una de las
investigaciones que tiene en contra lo
acusan de haberse quedado con las joyas
y regalos que el rey de Arabia Saudita
le dio a Brasil en 2021 cuando bolsonaro
era presidente nuestro periodista en
Brasil nos amplía
fue interrogado durante tres horas en
una comisaria de Brasilia para declarar
sobre los regalos que él y su esposa
recibieron el rey de Arabia Saudita unas
joyas valoradas en más de tres millones
de dólares habían sido incautadas por la
aduana brasileña en la mochila de un
ayudante de gobierno cuando volvió de
Arabia Saudita y varios funcionarios
intentaron después recuperarlas sin
éxito otros dos paquetes de regalos han
sido devueltos al estado en los últimos
días por los abogados de revolucionaron
después de una decisión del tribunal
Federal de compras ella revolucionario
es sospechado de intentar apropiarse
regalos que pertenecen a la colección
presidencial y de intentar hacerlos
entrar de contrabando a Brasil este caso
afecta gravemente su imagen como líder
anticorrupción pero en total él tiene
que responder de 16 acciones en la
justicia cualquiera de ellas podría
impedirle hacer elegido más que nunca Su
futuro político está en manos de la
justicia
otra noticia en Brasil es que un hombre
mató a cuatro niños con un hacha en una
guardería en el estado de Santa Catarina
en el sur en el ataque hirió a otros
cinco niños todos los menores tienen
entre tres y siete años un joven con
antecedentes penales se entregó a las
autoridades Mientras que el presidente
Luis Ignacio Lula da Silva creó un grupo
contra la violencia escolar ya que este
es el segundo ataque en un centro
estudiantil en tan solo 10 días
Valentina Torres Sánchez nos amplía
las lágrimas y el terror inundaron la
que iba a ser una mañana normal en la
ciudad de
un hombre de 25 años saltó un muro y
logró acceder a la guardería cantiño
buen pastor y atacó a varios menores de
Entre cuatro y siete años con un hacha
Posteriormente se entregó a las
autoridades
Cuando llegamos al lugar Confirmamos la
muerte de cuatro menores tres niños y
una niña otros cuatro menores resultaron
heridos uno de ellos En condición seria
y fueron asistidos
el presidente Luis Ignacio Silva condenó
a través de su cuenta de Twitter los
hechos que se presentaron a solo 10 días
de la apuñalamiento registrado en un
colegio de Sao Paulo en donde un
adolescente de 13 años acuchilló a una
profesora causándole la muerte e hirió a
otras cuatro personas no hay mayor dolor
que el de una familia que pierda a sus
hijos o nietos más aún en un acto de
violencia contra niños inocentes e
indefensos mis condolencias y oraciones
a las familias de las víctimas y la
comunidad de bloominado en medio de la
monstruosidad ocurrida en la guardería a
buen pastor
el gobierno del Estado de Santa Catarina
canceló las clases durante dos días y
declaró tres días de luto las
autoridades investigan si el presunto
responsable actuó solo o en compañía al
tiempo que intentan Acceder al teléfono
móvil y el computador del arrestado a su
vez informaron que el hombre ya tiene
antecedentes penales sin revelar por
cuales delitos
segundo día de confrontación en la
mezquita de alacsa en Jerusalén la
versión de wak la organización islámica
designada por Jordania para administrar
el complejo Es que la policía israelí
irrumpió lanzó granadas de aturdimiento
y disparó balas de goma para sacar a los
musulmanes que oraban por el ramadán
luego los fieles arrojaron objetos a los
uniformados es el segundo día
consecutivo en el que la policía
arremete contra la mezquita ayer realizó
una redada en la que arrestó a más de
350 personas La media luna roja
Palestina afirmó que 12 palestinos
resultaron heridos durante nada Y desde
la franja de gaza respondieron lanzando
cohetes contra Israel Turquía fue uno de
los países en rechazar el ataque contra
alaxa
romason
me gustaría expresar nuestra tristeza e
ir a por estas acciones terroristas de
la policía contra la mezquita de alaxa y
los musulmanes palestinos durante el mes
sagrado del ramadán
atacar a los civiles con bombas de
sonido porras y Balas de plástico es una
Clara señal de injusticia se ve
claramente que detrás de esta ola de
violencia que la administración israelí
ha infringido a pesar de todas las
advertencias están los problemas que
enfrentan la política interior
[Música]
afirma que Estados Unidos quebró el
compromiso que había hecho de respetar
la idea de un país dos sistemas respecto
a Taiwán y prometió una firme respuesta
la reacción fue de la cancillería luego
de que la presidenta taiwanesa se
reuniera en California con el presidente
de la cámara de representantes de
Estados Unidos El republicano Kevin
mccarthy por su parte la Casa Blanca
pidió a Beijing que no sobre reaccione a
los ojos de China una amenaza a su
soberanía para Estados Unidos un acto
diplomático común
tras su visita a Guatemala y Belice la
presidenta de Taiwán sáinway aterrizó en
California donde se reunió con el
presidente de la cámara de
representantes el republicano Kevin
mccarthy la tercera figura política más
importante de Estados Unidos
creo que nuestro vínculo es más fuerte
ahora que en cualquier otro momento de
la historia y por supuesto la presidenta
es una gran campeona Taiwán es una
democracia exitosa una economía próspera
y un líder Global en salud y ciencia a
su vez hay aseguró que mantenerse Unidos
los hace más fuertes
no es un secreto la paz que hemos
mantenido y la democracia en la que
hemos trabajado han enfrentado desafíos
sin precedentes Taiwán se esfuerza por
ser un socio confiable para el mundo una
piedra angular para la estabilidad en la
región hoy mismo la Casa Blanca calificó
la visita de un acto común de diplomacia
hemos dicho que no hay razón para que
Beijing convierta este tránsito en algo
usado como pretexto para sobre
reaccionar hemos sido claro
desde que se anunció la gira de
Centroamérica china aseguró que una
reunión con mccarthy acarrearía medidas
firmes ya en 2022 la visita Taiwán del
entonces presidenta del órgano
legislativo Nancy pelosi fue calificada
de traición deplorable por Beijing que
además sancionó a la funcionaria y
aumentó sus maniobras militares en el
estrecho de Taiwán
La Isla es uno de los mayores motivos de
conflicto entre China y Estados Unidos
principalmente porque Washington es el
mayor proveedor de armas de Taiwán dos
líderes europeos visitan China para
intentar afianzar la diplomacia el
primero en llegar a Beijing fue el
presidente francés Emmanuel antes de
hacerlo afirmó que Europa no debe
reducir los lazos con el gigante
asiático y dijo tener coincidencias con
el plan de paz que propone China para
Ucrania la comisionada de la Unión
Europea Úrsula Legend se unirá a la
visita en los próximos días aunque ella
es más reticente pues suele estar más
cercana a Estados Unidos y a la otan les
contamos en el siguiente informe
con la mira en las relaciones entre
Europa y China durante tres días y
Manuel macron y Úrsula ponder Legend
intentarán reanudar el diálogo con
Beijing en línea con el discurso de la
presidenta de la comisión europea del
jueves pasado
creo que no es viable ni redunda en
interés de Europa aislarnos de China
nuestra relación no es ni Blanca ni
negra y nuestra respuesta Tampoco puede
serlotte ambos líderes están Al filo de
la navaja con china el principal
objetivo de Manuel macron apoyarse en
Beijing para dar vuelta a la guerra en
Ucrania según el Eliseo china es una de
las únicas potencias capaces de poner
fin a la invasión rusa pero hace 15 días
se reunió con Vladimir Putin en Moscú en
Manuel macron Espera disuadir a Beijing
de entregar armas a Rusia Pero según
varias cancillerías occidentales es un
objetivo difícil de alcanzar otro eje de
la visita es al comercio macron está
acompañado por unos 60 grandes jefes
franceses entre ellos los de air y
veolia en la agenda firmas de contratos
para permitir un mejor acceso al mercado
chino Después de tres años de pandemia
un refuerzo de las relaciones económicas
deseado por china
está dispuesta a trabajar con Francia
para hacer de Esta visita una
oportunidad de promover nuevos
resultados en la estrecha y duradera
asociación estratégica global entre
China y Francia
el último punto sensible los Derechos
Humanos según el inicio se espera que
Manuel macron hable de la suerte de los
huijuries en chinyang una región del
Oeste de China donde Beijing es acusado
de perseguir a esta minoría ética y
terminamos con fútbol el Real Madrid se
clasificó a la final de la Copa del Rey
en España al vencer cuatro a cero al
Barcelona los blancos golearon a los
culés en el Camp Nou con una brillante
noche del delantero francés Karim
Benzema que marcó tres de las
anotaciones el otro tanto fue obra del
brasileño vinicius con este resultado el
equipo de la capital se enfrentará en la
final con el sorpresivo osasuna
hasta aquí las noticias sigan con France
[Música]